madame monsieur bonsoir
heureux qui comme gauthier a fait un
beau voyage le skipper français a
remporté aujourd'hui la deuxième édition
du vendée globe en arrivant à 16h24 est
précisément au port des sables d'olonne
terme d'un tour du monde en solitaire
sans escale et sans assistance
environ 46 mille kilomètres parcourus en
110 jours 2 heures 22 minutes et 39
secondes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux yann
lavoix et jean louis normandin
avec tout d'abord les premières
impressions du vainqueur à terre à terre
depuis une poignée de secondes seulement
le premier regard d'alain gautier va son
bateau à y ait un superbe attend de voir
de l'extérieur on retour en arrière
16h20 alain gautier et à 6 à la barre on
imagine le choc pour ce solitaire
escortés par des dizaines d'embarcations
on imagine la difficulté pour lui de
digérer si rapidement tous ces instants
merveilleux
16h22 c'est la victoire le tour du monde
et bouclé en 110 jours à la d'ordinaire
si réservé extériorise ta joie
ses jambes porte de nouveau ses premiers
mots par radio seront pour philippe jean
pour l'organisateur
bravo pour cette bataille et qui encore
une fois sous le soleil comme le départ
en tgv nautique
à la fal ses voiles pour entrer
doucement dans le chenal et mieux se
délecter des bravos poussé par des
milliers de vendéens venu faire de ce 12
mars un jour inoubliable
sandrine sa compagne et radieuse les
retrouvailles sont pathétiques mais que
l'ua s'est glissé à l'oreille le retour
du bonhomme sur la terre ferme mérité un
plus grand respect mais personne ne
voulait manquer ses premiers mots qui
sont allés à deux blocs valeureux
adversaires à nigel burgess décédé après
quelques jours de cours et puis au
public venu l'accueillir
on sait qu'on va convoyer de bien
accueilli mais ça n'est pas toujours
l'entendement est ce à quoi on pensait
il y avait du respect et de l'admiration
dans les yeux de chacun cet après midi
c'est pas tous les jours que l'on croise
un champion
on mesure encore mieux l'exploit en
rappelant que sur les 14 concurrents au
départ si seulement vont boucler ce tour
du monde en rappelant surtout que cette
course a été endeuillée par une double
disparition celle de mike plant et de
nigel burgess